but no one needs you know for example
like a semi a fully semi-automatic
so are you uncomfortable I know and
either I know I so you've never have you
ever fired a firearm Oh perfect that's
exactly what we want it was it because
of the magazine capacity no okay yeah it
does look really sinister hashtag I'm
with her up there would you be on board
with common sense gun reform what that
means
do you own any firearms shotgun well
sorry no no yep you can keep walking sir
today we're here with the Citizens
Coalition for common sense gun reform
CCC G our common sense
GSR to see what people know or don't
know about firearms and just how far
they're willing to give over the reins
to the federal government as far as
legislation based on that knowledge it's
common sense common sense as the firearm
debate rages on it's hard to delineate
between facts and buzzwords
semi-automatic assault rifle assault
rifle assault assault weapons are the
weapons of choice for mass shooters
automatic weapons semi-automatic assault
weapons assault what everyone's on board
with common sense right common sense
common sense measures common sense
measures hash tag common sense I like to
believe I have a shred of common sense
common sense common sense common sense
common sense we want to be common sense
and nobody really wants those scary
assault weapons on the streets right
we're here pushing for example common
sense assault weapons ban but what do
those terms actually mean if anything
legally more importantly what are the
people voting think they mean well are
you a firearm owner nope okay great are
you a gun owner you don't shoot guns you
don't own guns perfect good so are you a
firearm owner no okay good good good
good good well you know what you're not
for us but thank you I appreciate it you
can move along because we need him here
okay so you don't own guns you don't go
shooting good that's exactly we want so
you own any firearms oh good perfect
that's what we want signing this when
getting gun control pushed through it's
very important to make sure the people
on board are not firearm owners or just
better if they've never even seen a gun
that's how you get the signatures do you
like a sliding scale of what you think
should be okay to own versus what's
unreasonable what would be fine versus
what the government needs to step in and
ban right okay so yeah so you
right-leaning pop out at you though
you'd say like people don't need that
scary black one but something like this
no something like this illegal illegal
this no and this no one needs you know
something like an 8k they are right but
maybe maybe something like this like a
xxx yacht something like this okay so
that but that 22 we're good okay that's
not like this a hunting rifle yes
yeah well the wood in the metal hunting
rifle something like this another
hunting rifle 30.6 hunting rifle fine
with that
your basic lever action 357 you only get
13 rounds on that right off the bat
everybody had strong opinions and
feelings but how much do these experts
actually know about firearms
if any I don't know what that is that's
an Uzi well no one needs a fully
semi-automatic weapon careful careful
you never know when firearms can just
you know do their thing at the time
they're it's fully semi-automatic yeah
okay so know what many of these some of
these are fully fully semi-automatic
laws for those watching this who don't
yet know fully semi-automatic is a very
stupid made-up term by me to continue
well we can get into work play sure but
nobody needs a fully semi-automatic well
exactly I mean what's the reason for
like a fully semi-automatic ak-47 no one
no have you heard of the ar-15 that's
the bad one
ar-15 ar-15 C or 15a ours
you know seventies we are 15 yeah that's
I mean that's that's the really bad one
if you pay attention in the news that's
the one that's like that's the worst and
this is an ar-15 have you heard about
the air 15 it looks it looks worse right
yeah so is it because of the magazine
capacity look at it yeah it does look
really sinister a hunting you go oh no
you know no one hunts with us anyone who
needs a semi-automatic
they are 15 or a k47 right I mean what's
the deer is it a Rambo deer something
like wasn't I think 98% of mass
shootings use the ar-15 you wear that
like that's when it's used in like 90
what is it 99 point four of mass
shootings only none of that is true see
these actual statistics regarding mass
shootings
government should like you said round
him up gone we noticed a distinct trend
if the rifle was metal and wood people
were fine with it if it was black and
tactical looking they wanted it banned
I sound like John Stossel
this one's a personal favorite of mine
it mixes up a lot of people because it's
a lever action but you can fit 13 rounds
at 357 in there and you're getting close
to ak-47 ballistics how fast can you
fire it this fast my cameraman just peed
himself so with rifle knowledge that
seems pretty open and shut
let's see if they have any better luck
with him do you think anyone really
needs a handgun right no one's
committing mass shootings with these you
know right
I mean well let's do you think that
anyone really needs a handgun in 2016
maybe or maybe if you're like okay you
know you don't need an 8-round
handgun you know 10 runs to 22 or
something that's fine this
Rover's yeah six Chad well if it's a
revolver ten shots okay this revolver
that actually fits 10 rounds gets a lot
of people mixed up but in in areas like
this for defense it's common sense
I mean I understand why some
I think they have to have a gun for
self-protection and I feel sorry for
them it's common sense common sense sure
yeah you know that's why you call
someone else to ensure your livelihood
oh you're German okay German so German
Austrian Glock comes from you guys we
need you to petition them and make sure
they're not making them anymore there's
no need for them no better with handguns
surprise
turns out common sense opinions on guns
doesn't involve any actual knowledge of
guns let's see if they fare any better
with calibers this is just your basic
3006 hunting rifle something like this
you know a hunting rifle fine with that
yes yes that should be okay yeah where's
wooden metal it's a good rule of thumb
what about calibers you have an issue
for example what kind of caliber is okay
like in this this is 22 spoonfuls do you
think someone needs that here to hunt no
something like that can cause a lot of
damage think I think the deers done
where you going to the chopper I mean
that one was perfectly fine with a gun
that fires the thirty-aught-six but
thought that the 30-odd six-round should
be banned the wood in the metal confuses
people so maybe so maybe something like
like that yeah you know something
something like that's like as much
smaller hunting round right would be
reasonable and so you've got like a 22
deer is just as dead the Moose is just
as good dad if you have you know it is
one of these deer tastes just as good
tastes just as good in the table so
you're saying someone needs this to hunt
yes well on that we disagree sir I don't
I don't like armor-piercing and I don't
right there you go you don't know maybe
I do why do you not care about the
32,000 dead in the United States you
know about hollow points if it hits
somebody it basically explodes and it's
like like it it's like a watermelon
blowing up you come back to me when you
find your soul sir it blows up their
whole body well you could see right
through it yeah you could see the car
right behind them with a hollow-point
okay this next one is a magic trick okay
because everybody was against this gun
this gun and okay with this gun but had
a same round
they're voting your president one thing
- a lot of people miss this they don't
think about it gun storage firearms
storage that's where a lot of accidents
happen we just don't want people with
easily accessible like loaded firearms
you know just at a moment's notice
firearm has to be unloaded trigger guard
in a micro safe and a macro safe with
the bullets somewhere else
common sense basically so it's not
usable for home defense or anything
other than hunting or target shooting
does that seem common sense yeah that
myself in that way kid just doesn't get
it you know and just you know do you
don't know what he's gonna do am i
trying to take a nap with it so safe in
a safe and then bullets somewhere else
that scene with someone can be on board
with yeah
just uh just two safes in a trigger lock
without bullets it's common sense it's
on that that'd be great you know in ass
Micro safe in a macro safe yes a safe
inside a safe yeah two safes here's the
point where I go full Daniel day-lewis
and method act as an anti Second
Amendment activist using their most
common arguments first I've do you own
any firearms
that's not then thank you I could tell
that you seem like someone who's
probably you've seen politically engaged
active I can tell by the glasses are
you're basically against all no I'm not
but I'm just against asking people who
made not exhibit as much common sense as
we'd like oh yeah bullet regulation but
more importantly common sense clip
regulation yes that's a multi clip okay
now here's the thing about clips rights
like these are these are clips they use
these they use these terms that are
benign like they say magazine so you
think oh what is there Us Weekly or
people it's a clip it's a clip I hate me
too
do you own any firearms you got rid of
them look good you're safer because of
it if you own firearms you know you're
you're eighteen times more likely to
have an accident with a firearm in your
house yeah
well your dad has made you less safe by
having firearms in the house go tellin
that 32,000 Americans dead I consider
that an insult well I consider an insult
that you take part in you know what is
the thirty two thousand deaths of
Americans every year through firearms
32,000 Americans dead I don't care about
the lives that are lost to gun violence
senselessly
to each their own I guess all right well
that's fine most mass shooters are
educated that's a good point
common sense thirty thousand people to
gun violence ten thousand more people in
the time I just said that now it's
twelve thousand so you know there's
nothing nothing we can do here I mean
you guess I guess you guys are ok with
like another McVeigh so you're not a
firearm owner I take it well good
another Dylan roof I live in the hood
really and we're all my do all my good
thugs get their guns what you just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things I have ever heard we're trying to
stop a moment yeah all right get him
from the NRA yeah please remember don't
lock them up really well they don't go
out and buy illegal guns everyone in
this room is now Dumber for having
listened to it I wanna have responsible
firearms right deed that I go hunting in
the fall that's my family has for many
true
I don't own a handgun might not be so
responsible for that animal you're
hunting though huh so these people are
breaking in they're committing crimes
and we're just trying to fight it with
some common-sense legislation so
criminals don't break the law God have
mercy on your soul if you can't fly you
should be able to buy right no fly no
buy no-fly no-buy say no slider that
no-fly no-buy warned aloud on a plane
shouldn't be allowed to buy a gun in is
most unregulated bread what part of
their ass is a regulated militia no part
of your ass is part of a well-regulated
militia allows keeping abilities in the
country but yeah I know the plane I know
do you know what the process is like for
the no-fly list no I don't it's pretty
scrupulous here's a guy who has no idea
what the NRA I know if anything I want a
firearm owner to not be in the NRA I
want them to have never gone through an
NRA course this guy's possibly drunk on
the no-fly list you know you're either a
terrorist or another senators pulling a
prank what that's rare I don't want them
on the newsletter if they have to have a
gun I want them to have never even heard
of the Internet in volume Somalia
everybody's got a gun there it's true
all the Pirates in Swords look at me
short under the captain now no one needs
a gun for home defense hashtag I'm with
her well of course I mean she's the only
one that's just wants to support
anything like this yeah I mean what
self-respecting man would vote otherwise
hashtag on with her hashtag common sense
thank you yes thank you no home defense
no huh
no need there you go crazy cat guy
that's what we want signing hashtag
feminism
hashtag LGBTQ a IP hashtag common sense
let the NRA know that you don't want
them selling any more guns
he agrees see you at the polls
hashtag no semi-automatics Thank You
hashtag thank you thank you good luck
with mom moms demand action hashtag I'm
with her know that seats far up there
well there you have it the people who've
never owned guns fired guns or even seen
guns are the ones most likely to
remarkably quickly sign petitions to
actively ban your guns these are the
same people electing your next president
it's common sense
okay you're killing it that's enough
with that
speaking of common sense common sense
tells me that hopefully I can find one
active live round somewhere and blow my
head off it's a common sense don't say
it if you liked this video subscribe
how by hitting the big letters down
there that write out subscribe or you
can watch one of these other Second
Amendment centric videos playing in
boxes was the Second Amendment designed
for the militia only was it written just
for muskets just how much does Vox suck
and Young Turks lotta with Crider calm
for references and daily articles or
stay in the dark we don't care now are
you a firearm owner yourself okay no
great we're looking for people like that
to sign thank you very much appreciative
sir thank you you too